Before you see the movie about an evil fictional technology company,
see the story of Facebook: a real-life evil
technology company.
The Social Network
Experience the world's smartest film about
the world's dullest premise
"Did you answer affirmatively when Tyler
and Cameron Winklevoss
and Divya Narendra asked you to build harvard connection?"
"Did you say yes?"
In this dark Shakespearean drama about the website you're crazy aunt post minion memes on.
That uses snappy dialogue.
I deserve your attention -You have part
of my attention. You have the minimum amount.
Slick directing and great performances to make a story
where young millionaires sue each other for more money feel really high stakes
What was honorship share ?dialuded? down to?
"Point zero three percent"
That's still millions you greedy a**hole! C'mon, I'd sell my kidneys for point zero three percent of Neopets
Journey to Harvard,
where no one ever lets you forget.
It's Harvard.
"This is John Harvard. -We're gentlemen of Harvard."
Girls wanna get with guys who go to Harvard."
Harvard.
"This is Harvard."
And meet Mark Zuckerberg, a star student with a mind of a calculator, the heart of a troll
"Erica Albright's a bitch."
And the wardrobe of a comfy hobo.
He's determined to do two things with his life
Make a world respect him and
make sure Jesse Eisenberg
gets every awkward Know-it-All nerd Role in Hollywood.
Take that Michael Cera! "Ha!"
Coasting off Mark's talent are a succession
of hot dudes in suits, like:
Eduardo, the only Brazilian
who doesn't know how to party.
"You think this is such a good idea?"
"You think maybe we shouldn't shut it down before we get into trouble?"
"You want to end the party at 11."
"I'm trying to pay for the party."
Sean Parker, the man on the side
who gets in the way of their bromance
And the 'Winklevii', who briefly got your hopes up that Armie Hammer had an identical twin.
Or to put it another way...
Lex Luthor dumped Spider-Man for N-Sync and pisses off the Lone Ranger
If you want to know the real story behind Facebook,
watch something else, because they're bending the truth harder than the news your uncle posts on his wall
In a film that makes up the ex-girlfriend who
supposedly inspired the site.
Makes up an obsession with final clubs
that tears Mark's friendships apart.
"Tell me this isn't about getting into 'The Phoenix'?"
And makes him into an awkward scowling
robot where in real life
he was a normal dorky college kid.
-"Within a couple of weeks
Two thirds of the school had signed up
So, at that point, my roommates are kinda like,
'you know, this is pretty cool'
like whether this work at other schools."
But hey, don't let facts get in the way
I'm sure the real Sean Parker love seeing himself as a paranoid,
coked-out, cowardly, maybe sorta statutory rapist.
"How old are they, Sean?" -"It's not polite to ask."
-"Sean how old are they?"
So gather round for a film that's not really about Facebook.
It's about friendship, that still nails what
t's like to use the website
In this masterpiece of craft that proves Aaron Sorkin could make boring litigation exciting
"You stole our whole goddamn idea" -"Fellas..."
David Fincher could make applying for
an internship look awesome.
"Welcome to Facebook."
And Trent Reznor could make rowing down a calm river feel epic
[Electronic version of "In the Hall of the Mountain King" plays]
'Man, I wish they'd make another Facebook movie', is a sentence. I never thought I'd say in this lifetime
Starring...
Jesse Eisenberg as himself
Andrew Garfield, the Brazilian Jew?
Tim, from Jurassic Park
The cloned ranger
A single shade of Gray
He's a dick who knows DOS
And all the laptops who gave their lives so David fincher could get the perfect shot.
Site club
[Chat nearly muted out by club music]
I know it's realistic and everything, but trying to understand Sorkin dialogue at a loud bar,
is like your grandma trying
to understand how Facebook works.
"No, Nana, ugh, the search bar is not the same as the status update. Gah!"
Thanks for watching! Click the boxes above for more Honest Trailers
and let us know what movie you'd like to see get the honest treatment in the comments below